holden's mind shifted on most of the
questions
more food more drink more sleep more sex
any sex he was aware of a deep and
oceanic cavern of want in his belly
something that was like hunger or thirst
exhaustion or lust but that wouldn't be
satisfied he didn't have words for it
except that it left him quick to anger
and despair
lingering behind it all the fear that he
wouldn't ever have his crew back on his
ship made him feel gut-punched
and then the word for it came he was
homesick and the ross ante
wonderful as she was wasn't home unless
alex amos and naomi were in her he
wondered how long the feeling would last
if they never came back how long he'd
wait for them
even once he knew they wouldn't return
hey guys pete here
time to preview the upcoming sixth
episode of the expanse season five we'll
pick up the conversation we've been
having
from my breakdown of the last episode
there's some things i wanted to clear up
then we'll look at where each of the
character stories left off and where we
think they might go based on the details
we've been given
this will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the
expanse through
episode 5 of season 5 with speculation
on episode 6. as someone who's read the
books i'm going to be referring to them
but i won't give away
any future spoilers nothing past where
we're at with all that out of the way
let's jump in one of the things i wanted
to talk about in a little more detail
was this idea of what happened to the
rossi
what was up with holden getting ready to
take off it didn't really show them
looking for sabotage
i do think that's an important point
about the character of holden that there
is an impulsivity to him and his
decision making
and the other crew members who know this
certainly do help him
keep that in check but what's important
about the code isn't really about holden
and i realized when i read the comments
that i talk about the code like we
understand what that is
and really people watching the show
probably don't they haven't really
explained it completely yet
and it may not be exactly the same so
what's important about it is
that naomi created this for something
else and then marco used it to kill
people
he made her an accomplice to his crimes
that made her want to leave and marco
took phillip away
and hid him so that she couldn't be a
part of his life he did that to control
her
and he did it to keep her quiet about
what happened we'll likely learn more
about this in the coming episodes but
for now it's important to remember
marcos raised phillip to believe that
his mother abandoned him when in reality
he chased her away
related to that there was some
discussion about the knife that when he
pulled her into the lift whether he saw
that or not for me it doesn't make sense
that he would have let her keep it if he
knew what she was up to
nothing we've seen so far indicates that
he might be losing faith in marco or has
any kind of connection to her
he doesn't know her and while he did
save her by bringing her
from palace that was more about the idea
of his mother dying without having a
chance to meet her than
anything that exists between them i mean
i think so anyways
in the book it was different they lured
her there so that was the feeling i've
got from watching these season 5
episodes
you could see that when marco called him
out for bringing her he didn't look
angry he looked hurt he looked hurt
because his father
didn't approve of what he did now that
she's betrayed sin she's basically on
her own
marco using the code on the rossi was
necessary for her to figure out what was
going on
and then her finding a way to stop it
and that made it so it's going to be a
lot harder for her to make any kind of
moves against them
we saw her get locked in a cell more or
less and i do think that corral was
right
in that marco's not going to let her go
so she's going to have to come up with a
plan that's where naomi's at is that
she's locked up
she has no real chance of getting out
and she's going to have to figure out
something
holden's situation is sort of a question
mark i kind of feel like we won't see
much with him in the next couple
episodes he'll be slowed down because of
the code they'll have to check the rossi
and fix it
compared to the books it's kind of
backwards how it happened that's why i
think maybe we might not see much happen
with him there is a possibility that
something will come up with
monica or just the general aftermath of
fred's passing on tycho but i'm not
really sure
the main thing with holden is that he's
stuck there and we saw a little bit of
this in the last episode
where he can't even reach anybody during
this crisis
in the excerpt i read you know he gets
that feeling about
he doesn't know if he's gonna see his
crew again and it's a difficult
situation because he's the kind of guy
who likes to go out and do something and
where he's at now there's nothing he can
do
amos and peaches are also in a pretty
tough spot
they're on foot the prison was in a
pretty remote area
and as far as we can tell the world
should be falling apart
i say as far as we can tell because we
haven't heard too much about
how bad things are from the rocks
hitting the numbers we've heard have
been really low
and they're kind of suspicious and it
does kind of make sense that they would
do it this way
we're finding it out in real time amos
and peaches will be our eyes on the
ground and they did need to get out of
the building
first we can imagine that avasarala will
have access and we'll learn some more
about that from her as well
but as a book reader it is a little bit
frustrating at this point because
we can't be sure if it's going to be the
same situation or not
one thing we can count on is that amos
and clarissa will have to leave and they
will have to walk on foot
somewhere besides where they're at so we
had some pretty good reveals of how
destroyed the building they were in was
so i'm looking forward to seeing what
the rest of that region looks like from
their perspective
peaches was serving a life sentence
because of her mods she was kept
underground and she really
didn't think she would see outside ever
again she's sort of on that bonus time
or borrowed time kind of thing here we
saw that her health wasn't that great
but the blockers that she was on that
was blocking her modifications will wear
off
as you can imagine those may come in
handy for what they're up against
alex and bobby were able to survive the
attack they made it out of the
high-speed
chase they were being chased down by a
torpedo they dumped core
and they were able to destroy that they
could be in a bad spot if the ship that
was following them figured out what
happened
they would know that they're temporarily
like a sitting duck
they're not completely stranded though
basically when you dump core you're
venting all the energy that's built up
inside the fusion reactor
as long as you have more fuel you can
start it back up but that takes time
ty frank confirmed this on the after
show podcast that he does with west
chatham so it's not like they're stuck
out there in space for good but they
will have a little bit of down
time until they can escape this probably
means that they won't be able to see
where the free navy goes
next and it will be interesting to see
what their plan is
after this they said that the bar keith
was burning away from the sun
that means that soviter probably will
get away no one will be able to track
him immediately
so we'll have to wait and see what bobby
and alex's plan is from there
elsewhere in the belt drummer and her
faction made the decision that they're
gonna meet up with marco
as i said in my breakdown of this
episode their reactions don't seem to be
consistent
some seem more sympathetic with marco
and what he's trying to do
so i think there's real potential there
that they might split up or something
might happen
to undermine drummer's authority in
going against marco
trying to collect the bounty at the same
time it doesn't seem likely that she
would join up with the free navy
unless she does so under the pretenses
of having a plan to
take him out that way based on what
we've seen he has a far superior
fleet it's not clear that she knew this
before and so it's likely that when she
finds out
she'll have to figure out a plan if she
still wants to go after him
marco is in a pretty strong position
right now the coordinated nature of his
attack
has everyone back on their heels and his
using the proto-molecule as
a threat makes it more complicated for
anybody from the inner planets trying to
go after him the thing with him using
the gemara code is that he was never
caught for the original
attack naomi wrote it in a way that it's
mostly
undetectable in the book whenever naomi
makes the call to jim they'd already
been running system checks to see if
anything had been wrong with it
so even though we didn't see them do
that in the show it's very possible that
they did
and they weren't able to find it using
something like that is just another
example of where people have to fear him
they have to take him seriously
the gemara code makes the ship's
magnetic bottle fail
and that more or less turns the reactor
into a nuclear bomb
the ship becomes a nuclear bomb that was
why it was so crazy to see
sakai double down when she was locked in
the cell
she knew the ship was going to blow up
it was going to take a big part of the
station with it and it was probably
going to take her out as well
that's the kind of threat that makes all
the stations feel
unsafe and now belters are going to have
to decide if they're going to fall in
line behind the free navy or not
sin did a great job of laying out the
belter point of view
naomi's counter was that marco is
building this new reality
on a river of blood but from some
belter's perspective that's the status
quo
that's the way they see the inners
operating it's really the political
dilemma of the belt
i see a lot of hate towards the
character of naomi
because she gave fred the proto-molecule
you hear people say none of this would
have happened if naomi wouldn't have
given away the proto-molecule
it's no question that that turned out to
be a mistake but she wasn't necessarily
wrong in doing it at the time
it's the same as fred giving away
information to abasarala
remember when drummer quit over that
because he got tricked by marco
and he got a bunch of innocent belters
killed it's the same as drummer not
spacing marco
they're making tough decisions in
situations where both choices are bad
so now that marco has grabbed a little
bit of power he can use that to force
people in the belt to choose a side
some will see what he's done as what it
is an atrocity and they'll probably feel
more connected to humanity rather than
just to belters
but you can see that some people will
choose his side because it looks like
it's the better of two bad choices so i
think that's a good place to leave it
i'm interested to hear what you guys
think so let me know in the comments
i really do hope that we get some
answers to how bad the damage is
if it's the same as in the books or if
it's different so hopefully amos and
peaches will get on the road we'll see
some things first
hand and we'll also check in with
avasarala let me know what you want to
see what you're most interested in
and if you have any questions about
what's happened so far
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon